The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, we're ready to
start the eleventh lecture.
We're still in the
middle of sketching.
And, indeed, one of the
reasons why we did not
talk about hyperbolic
functions is
that we're running just
a little bit behind.
And we'll catch up
a tiny bit today.
And I hope all the way
on Tuesday of next week.
So let me pick up where we
left off, with sketching.
So this is a continuation.
I want to give you
one more example
of how to sketch things.
And then we'll go through
it systematically.
So the second example that we
did as one example last time,
is this.
The function is (x+1)/(x+2).
And I'm going to save
you the time right now.
This is very typical
of me, especially
if you're in a hurry
on an exam, I'll
just tell you what
the derivative is.
So in this case,
it's 1 / (x+2)^2.
Now, the reason why I'm
bringing this example up,
even though it'll turn out
to be a relatively simple one
to sketch, is that
it's easy to fall
into a black hole
with this problem.
So let me just show you.
This is not equal to 0.
It's never equal to 0.
So that means there
are no critical points.
At this point,
students, many students
who have been
trained like monkeys
to do exactly what
they've been told,
suddenly freeze and give up.
Because there's nothing to do.
So this is the one thing that
I have to train out of you.
You can't just give
up at this point.
So what would you suggest?
Can anybody get us
out of this jam?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the suggestion was
to find the x-values
where f(x) is undefined.
In fact, so now that's a
fairly sophisticated way
of putting the point
that I want to make,
which is that what we
want to do is go back
to our precalculus skills.
And just plot points.
So instead, you go
back to precalculus
and you just plot some points.
It's a perfectly
reasonable thing.
Now, it turns out that the
most important point to plot
is the one that's not there.
Namely, the value of x = -2.
Which is just what
was suggested.
Namely, we plot the points where
the function is not defined.
So how do we do that?
Well, you have to think
about it for a second
and I'll introduce some
new notation when I do it.
If I evaluate 2 at this
place, actually I can't do it.
I have to do it from
the left and the right.
So if I plug in -2 on the
positive side, from the right,
that's going to be equal
to -2 + 1 divided by -2,
a little bit more
than -2, plus 2.
Which is -1 divided by -
now, this denominator is -2,
a little more than that, plus 2.
So it's a little more than 0.
And that is, well we'll
fill that in in a second.
Everybody's puzzled.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No,
that's the function.
I'm plotting points,
I'm not differentiating.
I've already differentiated it.
I've already got something
that's a little puzzling.
Now I'm focusing
on the weird spot.
Yes, another question.
STUDENT: Wouldn't it be
a little less than 0?
PROFESSOR: Wouldn't it
be a little less than 0?
OK, that's a very good point
and this is a matter of notation
here.
And a matter of parentheses.
So wouldn't this be
a little less than 2.
Well, if the parentheses
were this way; that is, 2+ ,
with a minus after I did the
2+ , then it would be less.
But it's this way.
OK.
So the notation is,
you have a number
and you take the
plus part of it.
That's the part which is a
little bit bigger than it.
And so this is what I mean.
And if you like, here I can
put in those parentheses too.
Yeah, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why doesn't
the top one have a plus?
The only reason why the
top one doesn't have a plus
is that I don't need
it to evaluate this.
And when I take the limit, I
can just plug in the value.
Whereas here, I'm
still uncertain.
Because it's going to be 0.
And I want to know
which side of 0 it's on.
Whether it's on the positive
side or the negative side.
So this one, I could have
written here a parentheses 2+,
but then it would have
just simplified to -1.
In the limit.
So now, I've got a
negative number divided
by a tiny positive number.
And so, somebody want
to tell me what that is?
Negative infinity.
So, we just evaluated this
function from one side.
And if you follow
through the other side,
so this one here, you get
something very similar,
except that this should be--
whoops, what did I do wrong?
I meant this.
I wanted -2, the
same base point,
but I want to go from the left.
So that's going to be
-2 + 1, same numerator.
And then this -2 on
the left, plus 2,
and that's going to come
out to be -1 / 0-, -,
which is plus infinity.
Or just plain infinity, we don't
have to put the plus sign in.
So this is the first
part of the problem.
And the second piece, to
get ourselves started,
you could evaluate this
function at any point.
This is just the most
interesting point, alright?
interesting place
to evaluate it.
Now, the next thing
that I'd like to do
is to pay attention to the ends.
And I haven't really
said what the ends are.
So the ends are just all the
way to the left and all the way
to the right.
So that means x going to
plus or minus infinity.
So that's the second thing
I want to pay attention to.
Again, this is a little bit
like a video screen here.
And we're about to discover
something that's really
off the screen, in both cases.
We're taking care of what's
happening way to the left, way
to the right, here.
And up above, we
just took care what
happens way up and way down.
So on these ends, I need
to do some more analysis.
Which is related to
a precalculus skill
which is evaluating limits.
And here, the way to
do it is to divide
by x the numerator
and denominator.
Write it as (1 +
1/x) / (1 + 2/x).
And then you can see
what happens as x
goes to plus or minus infinity.
It just goes to 1.
So, no matter whether x
is positive or negative.
When it gets huge, these two
extra numbers here go to 0.
And so, this tends to 1.
So if you like, you
could abbreviate this
as f plus or minus
infinity is equal to 1.
So now, I get to draw this.
And we draw this
using asymptotes.
So there's a level
which is y = 1.
And then there's
another line to draw.
Which is x = -2.
And now, what information
do I have so far?
Well, the information
that I have so far
is that when we're coming in
from the right, that's to -2,
it plunges down
to minus infinity.
So that's down like this.
And I also know that it goes up
to infinity on the other side
of the asymptote.
And over here, I know it's
going out to the level 1.
And here it's also
going to the level 1.
Now, there's an issue.
I can almost finish
this graph now.
I almost have enough
information to finish it.
But there's one
thing which is making
me hesitate a little bit.
And that is, I don't know,
for instance, over here,
whether it's going to maybe
dip below and come back up.
Or not.
So what does it do here?
Can anybody see?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It can't
dip below because there
are no critical points.
What a precisely correct answer.
So that's exactly right.
The point here is that
because f' is not 0,
it can't double back on itself.
Because there can't be any
of these horizontal tangents.
It can't double back,
so it can't backtrack.
So sorry, if f' is not
0, f can't backtrack.
And so that means that it
doesn't look like this.
It just goes like this.
So that's basically it.
And it's practically
the end of the problem.
Goes like this.
Now you can decorate
your thing, right?
You may notice that maybe it
crosses here, the axes, you can
actually evaluate these places.
And so forth.
We're looking right now
for qualitative behavior.
In fact, you can see
where these places hit.
And it's actually a little
higher up than I drew.
Maybe I'll draw it accurately.
As we'll see in a second.
So that's what happens
to this function.
Now, let's just take a look
in a little bit more detail,
by double checking.
So we're just going to
double check what happens
to the sign of the derivative.
And in the meantime, I'm
going to explain to you
what the derivative
is and also talk
about the second derivative.
So first of all, the trick
for evaluating the derivative
is an algebraic one.
I mean, obviously you can do
this by the quotient rule.
But I just point out that this
is the same thing as this.
And now it has, whoops,
that should be a 2
in the denominator.
And so, now this has
the form 1 - 1/(x+2).
So this makes it easy to
see what the derivative is.
Because the derivative of
a constant is 0, right?
So this is, derivative, is just
going to be, switch the sign.
This is what I wrote before.
And that explains it.
But incidentally,
it also shows you
that that this is a hyperbola.
These are just two
curves of a hyperbola.
So now, let's check the sign.
It's already totally
obvious to us
that this is just
a double check.
We didn't actually even have
to pay any attention to this.
It had better be true.
This is just going to
check our arithmetic.
Namely, it's increasing here.
It's increasing there.
That's got to be true.
And, sure enough,
this is positive,
as you can see it's
1 over a square.
So it is increasing.
So we checked it.
But now, there's one more
thing that I want to just
have you watch out about.
So this means that
f is increasing.
On the interval minus
infinity < x < -2.
And also from -2 all
the way out to infinity.
So I just want to warn
you, you cannot say,
don't say f is increasing on
(minus infinity, infinity),
or all x.
OK, this is just not true.
I've written it on the
board, but it's wrong.
I'd better get rid of it.
There it is.
Get rid of it.
And the reason is, so first
of all it's totally obvious.
It's going up here.
But then it went
zooming back down there.
And here this was true,
but only if x is not -2.
So there's a break.
And you've got to pay
attention to the break.
So basically, the moral here is
that if you ignore this place,
it's like ignoring Mount
Everest, or the Grand Canyon.
You're ignoring the
most important feature
of this function here.
If you're going
to be figuring out
where things are going up
and down, which is basically
all we're doing, you'd
better pay attention
to these kinds of places.
So don't ignore them.
So that's the first remark.
And now there's just a little
bit of decoration as well.
Which is the role of
the second derivative.
So we've written down the
first derivative here.
The second derivative is
now -2 / (x + 2)^3, right?
So I get that from
differentiating this formula up
here for the first derivative.
And now, of course, that's
also, only works for x not equal
to -2.
And now, we can see that this
is going to be negative, let's
see, where is it negative?
When this is a
positive quantity,
so when -2 < x <
infinity, it's negative.
And this is where
this thing is concave.
Let's see.
Did I say that right?
Negative, right?
This is concave down.
Right.
And similarly, if I
look at this expression,
the numerator is always negative
but the denominator becomes
negative as well when x < -2.
So this becomes positive.
So this case, it was
negative over positive.
In this case it was negative
divided by negative.
So here, this is in the range
minus infinity < x < -2 And
here it's concave up.
Now, again, this is just
consistent with what
we're already guessing.
Of course we already
know it in this case
if we know that
this is a hyperbola.
That it's going
to be concave down
to the right of the vertical
line, dotted vertical line.
And concave up to the left.
So what extra piece
of information
is it that this is giving us?
Did I say this backwards?
No.
That's OK.
So what extra piece of
information is this giving us?
It looks like it's giving
us hardly anything.
And it really is giving
But it is giving us something
that's a little aesthetic.
It's ruling out the
possibility of a wiggle.
There isn't anything
like that in the curve.
It can't shift from
curving this way
to curving that way
to curving this way.
That doesn't happen.
So these properties say there's
no wiggle in the graph of that.
Alright.
So.
Question.
STUDENT: Do we define the
increasing and decreasing based
purely on the
derivative, or the sort
of more general definition
of picking any two points
and seeing.
Because sometimes there
can be an inconsistency
between the two definitions.
PROFESSOR: OK, so the
question is, in this course,
are we going to define
positive derivative as being
the same thing as increasing.
And the answer is no.
We'll try to use these
terms separately.
What's always true is
that if f' is positive,
then f is increasing.
But the reverse is
not necessarily true.
It could be very flat,
the derivative can be 0
and still the function
can be increasing.
OK, the derivative can
be 0 at a few places.
For instance, like some cubics.
Other questions?
So that's as much as I
need to say in general.
I mean, in a specific case.
But I want to get
you a general scheme
and I want to go through a
more complicated example that
gets all the features
of this kind of thing.
So let's talk about a general
strategy for sketching.
So the first part of this
strategy, if you like,
let's see.
I have it all plotted out here.
So I'm going to make sure
I get it exactly the way
I wanted you to see.
So I have, it's plotting.
The plot thickens.
Here we go.
So plot, what is it that
you should plot first?
Before you even think
about derivatives,
you should plot discontinuities.
Especially the infinite ones.
That's the first
thing you should do.
And then, you should plot
end points, for ends.
For x going to plus
or minus infinity
if there don't happen to be
any finite ends to the problem.
And the third thing you can
do is plot any easy points.
This is optional.
At your discretion.
You might, for instance,
on this example,
plot the places where the
graph crosses the axis.
If you want to.
So that's the first part.
And again, this is
all precalculus.
So now, in the second part we're
going to solve this equation
and we're going to plot the
critical points and values.
In the problem which we just
discussed, there weren't any.
So this part was empty.
So the third step is to decide
whether f', sorry, whether,
f' is positive or
negative on each interval.
Between critical
points, discontinuities.
The direction of the sign, in
this case it doesn't change.
It goes up here and
it also goes up here.
But it could go up here
and then come back down.
So the direction can change
at every critical point.
It can change at
every discontinuity.
And you don't know.
However, this
particular step has
to be consistent with 1
and 2, with steps 1 and 2.
In fact, it will
never, if you can
succeed in doing steps 1 and
2, you'll never need step 3.
All it's doing is
double-checking.
So if you made an arithmetic
mistake somewhere,
you'll be able to see it.
So that's maybe the
most important thing.
And it's actually the most
frustrating thing for me
when I see people working on
problems, is they start step 3,
they get it wrong, and then they
start trying to draw the graph
and it doesn't work.
Because it's inconsistent.
And the reason is
some arithmetic error
with the derivative
or something like that
or some other misinterpretation.
And then there's a total mess.
If you start with
these two steps,
then you're going to know
when you get to this step
that you're making mistakes.
People don't generally make as
many mistakes in the first two
steps.
Anyway, in fact you can
skip this step if you want.
But that's at risk of not
double-checking your work.
So what's the fourth step?
Well, we take a look at whether
f'' is positive or negative.
And so we're deciding on things
like whether it's concave
up or down.
And we have these
points, f''(x) = 0,
which are called
inflection points.
And the last step is just
to combine everything.
So this is this the
scheme, the general scheme.
And let's just carry it
out in a particular case.
So here's the function that
I'm going to use as an example.
I'll use f(x) = x / ln x.
And because the
logarithm-- yeah, question.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is, is this optional.
So that's a good question.
Is this optional.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, the question
is is this optional,
this kind of question.
And the answer is,
it's more than just--
so, in many instances, I'm
not going to ask you to.
I strongly recommend that
if I don't ask you to do it,
that you not try.
Because it's usually awful to
find the second derivative.
Any time you can get
away without computing
a second derivative,
you're better off.
So in many, many instances.
On the other hand,
if I ask you to do it
it's because I want you
to have the work to do it.
But basically, if
nobody forces you to,
I would say never
do step 4 here.
Other questions.
All right.
So we're going to
force ourselves
to do step 4, however,
in this instance.
But maybe this will be
one of the few times.
So here we go, just for
illustrative purposes.
OK, now.
So here's the function
that I want to discuss.
And the range has
to be x positive,
because the logarithm is not
defined for negative values.
So the first thing
that I'm going to do
is, I'd like to follow
the scheme here.
Because if I don't
follow the scheme,
I'm going to get
a little mixed up.
So the first part is to
find the singularities.
That is, the places
where f is infinite.
And that's when the logarithm,
the denominator, vanishes.
So that's f(1+), if you like.
So that's 1 / ln(1+),
which is 1 / 0,
with a little bit of
positiveness to it.
Which is infinity.
And second, we do
it the other way.
And not surprisingly, this comes
out to be negative infinity.
Now, the next thing I
want to do is the ends.
So I call these the ends.
And there are two of them.
One of them is f(0)
from the right.
f(0+).
So that is 0+ / ln(0+),
which is 0+ divided by, well,
ln(0+) is actually
minus infinity.
That's what happens
to the logarithm, goes
to minus infinity.
So this is 0 over infinity,
which is definitely 0,
there's no problem about
what happens to this.
The other side, so this is the
end, this is the first end.
The range is this.
And I just did
the left endpoint.
And so now I have to
do the right endpoint,
I have to let x go to infinity.
So if I let x go
to infinity, I'm
just going to have
to think about it
a little bit by plugging
in a very large number.
I'll plug in 10^10,
to see what happens.
So if I plug in 10^10 into x /
ln x, I get 10^10 / ln(10^10).
Which is 10^10 / (10 ln(10)).
So the denominator,
this number here,
is about 2 point something.
2.3 or so.
So this is maybe 230
in the denominator,
and this is a number
with ten 0's after it.
So it's very, very large.
I claim it's big.
And that gives us the
clue that what's happening
is that this thing is infinite.
So, in other words,
our conclusion
is that f of
infinity is infinity.
So what do we have so
far for our function?
We're just trying to build the
scaffolding of the function.
And we're doing it by taking
the most important points.
And from a mathematician's
point of view,
the most important
points are the ones which
are sort of infinitely obvious.
For the ends of the problem.
So that's where we're heading.
We have a vertical
asymptote, which is at x = 1.
So this gives us x = 1.
And we have a value which
is that it's 0 here.
And we also know that when
we come in from the-- sorry,
so we come in from
the left, that's
f, the one from the left,
we get negative infinity.
So it's diving down.
It's going down like this.
And, furthermore, on the other
side we know it's climbing up.
So it's going up like this.
Just start a little higher.
Right, so.
So far, this is what we know.
Oh, and there's one
other thing that we know.
When we go to plus infinity,
it's going back up.
So, so far we have this.
Now, already it should
be pretty obvious what's
going to happen
to this function.
So there shouldn't
be many surprises.
It's going to come
down like this.
Go like this, it's going to
turn around and go back up.
That's what we expect.
So we don't know that yet,
but we're pretty sure.
So at this point, we can start
looking at the critical points.
We can do our step 2 here -
we need a little bit more room
here - and see what's
happening with this function.
So I have to differentiate it.
And it's, this is
the quotient rule.
So remember the function
is up here, x / ln x.
So I have a (ln x)^2
in the denominator.
And I get here the derivative
of x is 1, so we get 1 *
ln x minus x times
the derivative of ln
x, which is 1/x.
So all told, that's
(ln x - 1) / (ln x)^2.
So here's our derivative.
And now, if I set this equal to
0, at least in the numerator,
the numerator is 0 when x = e.
The log of e is 1.
So here's our critical point.
And we have a critical
value, which is f(e).
And that's going to be e / ln e.
Which is e, again.
Because ln e = 1.
So now I can also plot
the critical point,
which is down here.
And there's only one of
them, and it's at (e, e).
That's kind of
not to scale here,
because my blackboard
isn't quite tall enough.
It should be over here
and then, it's slope 1.
But I dipped it down.
So this is not to
scale, and indeed
that's one of the
things that we're not
going to attempt to do
with these pictures,
is to make them to scale.
So the scale's a
little squashed.
So, so far I have
this critical point.
And, in fact, I'm going
to label it with a C.
Whenever I have a
critical point I'll just
make sure that I remember
that that's what it is.
And since there's only one,
the rest of this picture
is now correct.
That's the same mechanism that
we used for the hyperbola.
Namely, we know there's
only one place where
the derivative is 0.
So that means there
no more horizontals,
so there's no more backtracking.
It has to come down to here.
Get to there.
This is the only place
it can turn around.
Goes back up.
It has to start here and
it has to go down to there.
It can't go above 0.
Do not pass go, do
not get positive.
It has to head down here.
So that's great.
That means that this picture is
almost completely correct now.
And the rest is more
or less decoration.
We're pretty much done
with the way it looks,
at least schematically.
However, I am going to punish
you, because I warned you.
We are going to go over
here and do this step 4
and fix up the concavity.
And we're also going
to do a little bit
of that double-checking.
So now, let's
again-- just, I want
to emphasize-- We're going
to do a double-check.
This is part 3.
But in advance, I already
have, based on this picture
I already know what
has to be true.
That f is decreasing on 0 to 1.
f is also decreasing on 1 to e.
And f is increasing
on e to infinity.
So, already, because we
plotted a bunch of points
and we know that there
aren't any places where
the derivative
vanishes, we already
know it goes down, down, up.
That's what it's got to do.
Now, we'll just make sure that
we didn't make any arithmetic
mistakes, now.
By actually computing
the derivative,
or staring at it, anyway.
And making sure
that it's correct.
So first of all, we just
take a look at the numerator.
So f', remember, was
(ln x - 1) / (ln x)^2.
So the denominator is positive.
So let's just take a
look at the three ranges.
So we have 0 < x < 1.
And on that range, the
logarithm is negative,
so this is negative divided by
positive, which is negative.
That's decreasing, that's good.
And in fact, that also
works on the next range.
1 < x < e, it's negative
divided by positive.
And the only reason why
we skipped 1, again,
is that it's undefined there.
And there's something
dramatic happening there.
And then, at the last range,
when x is bigger than e,
that means the logarithm
is already bigger than 1.
So the numerator
is now positive,
and the denominator's still
positive, so it's increasing.
So we've just double-checked
something that we already knew.
Alright, so that's
pretty much all
there is to say about step 3.
So this is checking the
positivity and negativity.
And now, step 4.
There is one small point which
I want to make before we go on.
Which is that
sometimes, you can't
evaluate the function or its
derivative particularly well.
So sometimes you can't
plot the points very well.
And if you can't plot
the points very well,
then you might
have to do 3 first,
to figure out what's
going on a little bit.
You might have to skip.
So now we're going to go on
to the second derivative.
But first, I want to
use an algebraic trick
to rearrange the terms.
And I want to notice
one more little point.
Which I-- as I say, this is
decoration for the graph.
So I want to
rewrite the formula.
Maybe I'll do it
right over here.
Another way of writing this
is 1/(ln x) - 1/(ln x)^2.
So that's another way of
writing the derivative.
And that allows me
to notice something
that I missed, before.
When I solved the equation ln x
- 1 - this is equal to 0 here,
this equation here.
I missed a possibility.
I missed the possibility
that the denominator
could be infinity.
So actually, if the
denominator's infinity,
as you can see from the
other expression there,
it actually is true that
the derivative is 0.
So also when x = 0+, the
slope is going to be 0.
Let me just
emphasize that again.
If you evaluate using this
other formula over here,
this is 1/(ln(0+))
- 1/(ln(0+))^2.
That's 1 over -infinity - minus
1 over infinity, if you like,
squared.
Anyway, it's 0.
So this is 0.
The slope is 0 there.
That is a little piece of
decoration on our graph.
It's telling us, going
back to our graph here,
it's telling us this is coming
in with slope horizontal.
So we're starting out this way.
That's just a little
start here to the graph.
It's a horizontal slope.
So there really were two places
where the slope was horizontal.
Now, with the help of
this second formula
I can also differentiate
a second time.
So it's a little bit easier to
do that if I differentiate 1
over the log, that's -(ln
x)^(-2) 1/x + 2 (ln x)^(-3)
1/x.
And that, if I put it
over a common denominator,
is x (ln x)^3 times,
let's see here,
I guess I'll have to
take the 2 - ln x.
So I've now
rewritten the formula
for the second
derivative as a ratio.
Now, to decide the sign, you
see there are two places where
the sign flips.
The numerator crosses
when the logarithm is 2,
that's going to be when x = e^2.
And the denominator
flips when x = 1,
that's when the log flips
from positive to negative.
So we have a couple
of ranges here.
So, first of all, we have
the range from 0 to 1.
And then we have the
range from 1 to e^2.
And then we have the range
from e^2 all the way out
to infinity.
So between 0 and
1, the numerator
is, well this is a
negative number and this,
so minus a negative
number is positive,
so the numerator is positive.
And the denominator is negative,
because the log is negative
and it's taken to
the third power.
So this is a negative
number, so it's positive
divided by negative,
which is less than 0.
That means it's concave down.
So this is a concave down part.
And that's a good thing,
because over here this
was concave down.
So there are no wiggles.
It goes straight
down, like this.
And then the other two pieces
are f'' is equal to, well
it's going to switch here.
The denominator
becomes positive.
So it's positive over positive.
So this is concave up.
And that's going over here.
But notice that it's not the
bottom where it turns around,
it's somewhere else.
So there's another
transition here.
This is e^2.
This is e.
So what happens at the end is,
again, the sign flips again.
Because the numerator, now,
when x > e^2, becomes negative.
And this is negative divided
by positive, which is negative.
And this is concave down.
And so we didn't quite
draw the graph right.
There's an inflection
point right here,
which I'll label with an
I. And it makes a turn
the other way at that point.
So there was a wiggle.
There's the wiggle.
Still going up, still
going to infinity.
But kind of the slope
of a mountain, right?
It's going the other way.
This point happens
to be (e^2, e^2 / 2).
So that's as detailed
as we'll ever get.
And indeed, the
next game is going
to be avoid being-- is to
avoid being this detailed.
So let me introduce
the next subject.
Which is maxima and minima.
OK, now, maxima and minima,
maximum and minimum problems
can be described graphically
in the following ways.
Suppose you have a
function, right, here it is.
OK?
Now, find the maximum.
And find the minimum.
OK.
So this problem is done.
The point being, that it is
easy to find max and the min
with the sketch.
It's very easy.
The goal, the problem, is that
the sketch is a lot of work.
We just spent 20 minutes
sketching something.
We would not like to
spend all that time
every single time we want to
find a maximum and minimum.
So the goal is to do it
with-- so our goal is
to use shortcuts.
And, indeed, as I said
earlier, we certainly
never want to use the second
derivative if we can avoid it.
And we don't want to
decorate the graph
and do all of these
elaborate, subtle,
things which make the graph
look nicer and really,
or aesthetically appropriate.
But are totally unnecessary
to see whether the graph is
up or down.
So essentially,
this whole business
is out, which is a good thing.
And, unfortunately,
those early parts
are the parts that
people tend to ignore.
Which are typically,
often, very important.
So let me first tell
you the main point here.
So the key idea.
Key to finding maximum.
So the key point
is, we only need
to look at critical points.
Well, that's actually
what it seems
like in many calculus classes.
But that's not true.
This is not the end
of the sentence.
And, end points, and
points of discontinuity.
So you must watch out for those.
If you look at the example
that I just drew here,
which is the one
that I carried out,
you can see that there are
actually five extreme points
on this picture.
So let's switch.
So we'll take a look.
There are five places where
the max or the min might be.
There's this important point.
This is, as I say, the
scaffolding of the function.
There's this point, there
down at minus infinity.
There's this, there's
this, and there's this.
Only one out of five
is a critical point.
So there's more that you
have to pay attention to
on the function.
And you always have
to keep the schema,
the picture of the function,
in the back of your head.
Even though this may be
the most interesting point,
and the one that you're
going to be looking at.
So we'll do a few examples
of that next time.